Byram we robbed in Venice now that's
some wild things going on with this
error
I'm still pretty impressed that we fit
our entire life into two bags hey Jen
you made it to the train station
I'm really sure what this is but we
basically have been desperate for iced
coffee so I think it might be a
milkshake but it says shake it it says
copy
I see lots of ice cream ice cream
nice coffee see baby I'm trained we're
off we have to walk somewhere to catch
water
the water is pretty much the prettiest
thing that I've ever done like I uh I'm
like wait you just get on it they'll get
a water taxi
we're at the Venice Oh what this is the
saddest little view I've ever seen
and we don't have a good view no I see
your line and the telephone not good for
you hope you get a new one I'm not
moving rooms let's go picking up to the
roof how do we get there the other
elevator our TVs on traveling like this
is exhausting it's extremely extremely
exhausting it's really fun Wow my body
is not a wonderland where do you that
I'm gonna hit you I will snap you with a
Nutella stick a real quick wardrobe
change now we're off to dinner
I forgot might as well it's gonna be
getting dark soon
it's dinner I'm taking a really
wonderful time-lapse and Jenna's very
upset about it
I always get the time laughs if we're
just looking get them I say you can use
them if I do
I mean it
look at my spaghetti my spaghetti my
spaghetti look at your spaghetti that's
nice
the s'ghetti
says he got the same skin
I'm not sure how I feel about the 23
frame rate that I'm shooting in today
I've been shooting in 60 and 120 this
whole trip but I was like you know what
maybe I'll try to be a little more artsy
on this bad idea too late
so how do you feel about my frame rate
oh it's bad here
this is just a quick little travel day
vlog so tomorrow we're going to be doing
a tour of Venice and I'm not sure what
else we're going to be doing but as
always stay tuned see you guys later
I'm ready for bed that was your video
for today don't sass me that's our tour
guide and she's moving the world right
now